frieda boas ist es ist ja im september
um diese zeit waren sehen wie 32 grad
und jetzt alle sind 14 grad und stand so
ist der bug in summe richtig das wetter
ja ich könnte ja so kalt wie duffy was
sagst du so zu dem wetter hier gerade in
deutschland beziehungsweise zu bist du
bescheuert klavier und ich werden uns
jetzt auf jeden fall
ich wollte sagen dass wir uns jetzt
frühstück machen warum steht hier eine
luftpumpe graz um hat wo ich meine
eltern geholt haben und sobald ich nach
meinem team morgen um 10 uhr spur mit
wieder fällt böden bis zu 90 km/h
das wird gleich unser meines blogs wird
auch der kommentar geschrieben hey luca
wer ist eigentlich dieser das ist dieter
kürzlich eine ahnung wer das es aber auf
jeden fall werde ich jetzt erstmal haben
ich glaube die brust ab gelaufen ich bin
hier gerade im schnitt vom block gehen
ihr vor zwei tagen gesehen habt
allerdings muss ich den schnitt jetzt
unterbrechen weil ich jetzt zum zahnarzt
muss sie zählen nicht zum ziel hat
sondern zu kieferorthopäden der guckt ob
meine
daraus sollen und da die wehtun glaube
ich schon dass die raus wollen wir
fahren jetzt der weisheitszahn
besprechung
weil jetzt gerade beim sc freiburg beim
kieferchirurgen wir haben tatsächlich
jetzt einen termin festgemacht an dem
meine psx scene rauskommen ja ich habe
es tatsächlich viel mehr weniger
operationen die demnächst anstehen und
zwar einerseits wegen meinem knie da
habe ich seitdem hier nur noch die für
komische verletzung dann habe ich hier
in meinem kinde muttermal und das ist
irgendwie so hervorgehoben und das muss
auch irgendwie ausgenommen werden weil
man beim rasieren habe ich da als
schmerz und das könnte timmer und weiter
sofort dann habe ich an der lippe hier
oben noch irgendwie was und all die
weisheitszähne misst noch ausgenommen
werden also hey mein leben jetzt als
nett bin geil aber eher freunde es gibt
schlimmeres im leben sobald es gibt
schlimmeres als vier operation in
nächster zeit zu haben ich kann doch
einfach mal flach ii fragen ob der die
operation vielleicht eben schnell machen
könnte würdest du dir zu trauen einfach
die operation hier vorne gerade im block
hoch denn hier von zwei tagen gesehen
habt und schaut euch mal meine texte
nicht einmal so einpacken
klopp ich gelacht böse nicht böse
freundlich locker dass man leichter ich
bestelle es auf jeden fall erstmal
chinesisches dann einmal die nummer
einmal
bei den chinesen bei dem ich daran
gerufen habe der hat einfach nichts
verstanden ich musste alles irgendwie
10.000 wir holen auf jeden fall deutlich
dass es erst mal ab das heißt machen
einfach ganz schnell freunde das alles
hier haben wir einfach bestellt das sind
irgendwie zehn verschiedene gerichte für
vier personen in unserer familie
übrigens wird heute abend das neue
iphone vorgestellt das hier braucht die
sonne blendet ganz schön nach vorne also
ich weiß jetzt der zeit von 8 heißt oder
iphone apps oder keine ahnung wie das
heißen soll aber ich freue mich dann
schon weg kraft braucht und ich glaube
ich werde dem flop man so ein bisschen
darauf reagieren so so so
da frag ich habe die soße vergessen du
wolltest ja keine vorsorge nebel team
ist lange in glück und zufriedenheit
leben hier vorne wird gerade das iphone
also sind nicht hier vorgestellt wird in
san francisco vorgestellt
aber hier ist gerade dieser livestream
und bisher ist es eigentlich genauso wie
das bisherige iphone hatte mainz nicht
auch schon stereo speaker das sind
bisher genau die gleichen sachen die
immer gesagt werden und wir haben in den
westen chip und fotos sind ein bisschen
besser und todes ein bisschen besser was
ist denn besonders krasse jetzt an den
neuen iphone
genau das habe ich gesagt jetzt aber
dass die kamera wieder ein bisschen
besser ist der typ hier vorne hatten
iphone in der hand und filmt einfach
diesen tisch und da steht nichts drauf
aber hier steht auf dem tisch trotzdem
was drauf und er bewegt sich so und
zeigt dann so hier filmt den tisch da
ist nichts drauf und er zeigt keine
regung oder er filmt den tisch und auf
dem tisch ist nichts drauf und lernte
ich meine also apple aufwendet reality
schon ganz nah
endlich war dachte scheiße
etwa drauflegen des les trois ich muss
nicht so endlich alt er hat sich mal
vorgestellt und man muss das handy nur
angucken und das erkennt ein was die
klingt ganz teil apple ich frage mich
heute nur grad wie ich mal alt von
extern sperren soll wenig versonnen
rolle auf habt ihr daran gedacht okay
haben hat gesagt dass das iphone mit
lernt und selbst eine kennen kann wenn
man 40 im bad hat ich werde ihn bat
haben das hier bin ich so liebe lässt
und das liegt direkt übertragen auf dem
ortsschild dass man mit dem scheißhaufen
vor wie gaal werde aus es geht so gar
nicht dem scheißhaufen oh mein gott was
das soll wieder typisch luke an die
stelle ganz übel stylen technischen
details technischen daten in den dingen
vor den neuen chip und somit liegen sie
mich animiert geschaffen die aktuelle
kino das zu ende
das iphone 8 hat mich jetzt nicht
überzeugt aber das heißt vom 10
das einfach nix das also aber ich
brauche ein iphone 10
ich kommentiere das spielezimmer so ein
bisschen hoffentlich spielt er den ball
jetzt zu mir die wahrheit muss man
finden hier da kommt damit sie hin ja
genau hier spazieren ein bisschen auf
den boden wo könnte ich den ball denn
in schießen ok der schiedsrichter gibt
den ball frei und wir sehen jetzt den
freistoß tiago tritt an eines materials
drin xabi alonso kann den freistoß
gerade gar nicht getreten haben er hat
aufgehört mit fußballspielen spaß
biochemisch mit der ecke und die ecke
kommen cool und jetzt ist er da ist der
fall geklärt und jungs noch klinisch
basti mal zurück hier auf tiago und
jetzt ganz zurück zuerst das center for
no raffiniert jetzt nehme ich mal
einfach den ball und rennen hier durch
und passt zu meinem freund jahr gemacht
dass ich mich auch gut und opas darüber
wen haben wir ja außen wieder joshua
kimmig er den ersten von anderlecht aus
passte zum gegner
rsc anderlecht jetzt mit der chance sie
laufen auf das habt ihr toll gemacht
wer hat denn wo er dringe auf den kopf
geschossen wenn ich eins nicht werden
sollte dann tatsächlich sport
kommentator
ich bin ja auch schon best blogger ist
man kann ja nicht alles
informationsgehalt von mir meiner
schwester und kommt einmal sehe ich so
dass hier
wer macht so einer scheiße resident
nicht so gesehen würde dann für dich
dich nicht auf den mond schießen ganz in
bar tauche ich würde wachsen ich gehe
jetzt erstmal es ist gerade 56 freunde
ich gehe es erstmal duschen und
zähneputzen und danach sehen wir uns
wieder besser
ist mittlerweile 37 ich bin geduscht
habe ich wenig geputzte fühle ich mich
dadurch jetzt nicht unbedingt aber wisst
ihr was ziemlich gerade zur frage also
einfach mal so ich mache es war das
fenster auf natürlich machen sind dem
moment gerade nichts doch da machen wir
was ich glaube halt was ich meine und es
ist gerade 7 uhr 30 in diesem
wirklichkeit nach viertelstunde bei
unseren nachbarn irgendwie an bord
dürfen
davon darf ich weiß auf jeden fall erst
mal zum arzt wie fall zumal der als der
- vorbei wir sind jetzt noch hier kommen
die pizza zum frühstücksbuffet gegangen
das beginnt jetzt echt nicht so gut
ich glaub doppelmoral brot und müsli und
das ist auch schon alles was sie hier
gebratener reis mit süß aber so ein buch
ist gewürzt schmeckt tatsächlich das
gerade meine damen und herren war ein
ganz kleiner ausschnitt von justin
bieber love your self kann schon ca 100
vom ganzen stück spielen
einige stunden sind vergangen meine
damen und herren das ist mittlerweile
tatsächlich schon 9 uhr ich habe euch im
letzten block eigentlich versprochen
dass in diesem blog langes luca reagiert
kommt kann ich mich an versprechungen
nie so wirklich halten ich werde aber
auf jeden fall in zukunft zu machen das
noch normale videos neben den blogs
kommen dadurch vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger blogs kommen und nur von tagen
an denen wirklich was passiert und so
weiter und so fort weil sie da
irgendwelche ideen zu unterteilungen
habt könnt ihr mir das gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
auf jeden fall hat sich gerade sehr sehr
viele besprechungen mit steuerberater
hat dies dass die da ganz papierkram es
ja auch gemacht werden wo ist aber jetzt
muss ich erst mal die zähne
[Musik]
das tut mir die bereits wirklich sehr
sehr leid dass heute keinen chor
reagiert dem block gekommen ist er kennt
mich
ich bin einfach ein dummer spaßt ich
kann euch auf jeden fall versprechen
dass ich im morgigen blog zurück nach
köln fahren werde ich mit mark wieder
sehen und wir werden tolle sachen machen
nicht das was ihr denkt allerdings würde
ich an der stelle jetzt den heutigen
glaubhaft beenden wenn ihr euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich sehr über eine live
freuen weiß ich schon abonnent von einem
kanal seite alles richtig gemacht halt
noch nicht können sie unter dem video
einfach auf abonnieren klicken denn
verpasst ihr einfach keine videos mehr
schreibt mir wie bereits gesagt bitte
einfach mal so ein plan gegen die
kommentare wie ihr das auf einem kanal
machen würdet mit abwechselnd blogs
normale videos oder nur blogs wenn was
interessantes passiert oder keine ahnung
aber sonst nicht sagen hey wies
[Musik]